commentaires bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin alors
plusieurs questions à où va
l'agriculture un exploitant sur deux à
plus de 50 ans la France est-elle
suffisamment ses agriculteurs aura-t-on
demain une souveraineté alimentaire
est-ce qu'on l'a on va la préserver quel
produit quel prix des agriculteurs ou
des jardiniers avec les questions de
l'environnement et puis évidemment la
sécheresse c'est ce que nous allons
aborder avec vous en évoquant quelques
autres sujets à commencer tout de même
on va en dire un mot sur la réforme des
retraites une réaction à ce qu'a dit
hier votre collègue du gouvernement
Gabriel Attal au Sénat il a dit ici au
moins nous ne sommes pas j'espère dans
une ZAD vous qui avez été des ministres
des relations avec avec le Parlement
vous auriez pris le même discours c'est
à dire qu'il y avait une ZAD à
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'on espère
autre chose au Sénat chacun emploie les
mots qui veut moi je constate quand même
que ça ressemble les singulièrement à ça
à l'Assemblée nationale
parce qu'au fond c'est quoi c'est ce qui
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est sous couvert de démocratie le
refus de la démocratie c'est-à-dire du
débat le Parlement ça veut dire le lieu
on parle le menthe on parle
or manifestement il y a un certain
nombre de gens qui n'étaient pas là pour
parler mais qui était le plus tôt là
pour injecter
et je trouve qu'ils font mal à la
démocratie parce qu'on a besoin d'une
Assemblée nationale on a besoin de
controverse à l'Assemblée nationale on a
des besoins de débat on a besoin de ne
pas être d'accord et trouver des voies
de compromis au fond quand on se donne
même pas les moyens les la capacité à
voter à débattre on met en scène une
forme d'impuissance auxquelles
on peut avoir quand vous regardez les
grands déballés parfois les grands
débats l'Assemblée nationale je remonte
à des dizaines d'années mais il y a
peut-être pas besoin de monter il y
avait une forme de virulence une forme
de controverse très forte mais il y
avait quand même la volonté qu'on puisse
aller au bout d'un vote d'un débat de de
l'échange d'idées hors ce à quoi on a
assisté aux reconnaissant le relevez
plus de l'échange d'invectif que de
l'échange d'idées oui le marc féno
Olivier Véran n'a pas forcément calmé
les choses ne portent parole du
gouvernement quand il dit attention avec
le 7 mars il y a un blocage
ça va nous mener à une catastrophe
écologique
j'ai pas vu l'entièreté pardon je suis
au salon donc je suis pas je suis dans
une bulle je sais pas si elle est
préserver d'ailleurs une bulle avec
d'autres sujets
les Français exprimeront ce qu'ils ont à
exprimer le 7 mars
on a besoin de cette réforme c'est celle
du sujet on n'a pas besoin non plus je
vois ce qui me gêne un peu parfois chez
certains c'est l'expression de on va
mettre en rade le pays on va on va
mettre à genoux on va mettre à genoux
l'économie mais c'est pas l'économie
qu'on met à jour
c'est pas l'économie combien genou c'est
les Français qu'on met à genoux quand on
fait ça parce que si l'économie va mal
c'est pas c'est pas une chose informe et
sans visage d'économie d'économie c'est
des salariés des chefs d'entreprise de
la richesse des retraites qu'on paye des
impôts qui permettent de financer donc
je suis pas sûr que mettre à genoux
l'économie soit un objectif dans une vie
et même dans une vie tout court d'un
pays je pense que la vie d'un pays c'est
d'essayer de trouver des équilibres mais
si la France était à l'arrêt est-ce que
sur un plan agricole ce serait il y a un
risque aussi de catastrophe comme le dit
Olivier on va pas vivre au mois de
septembre c'était on va pas avoir
d'énergie au mois de février c'est le
gouvernement qui le disait
le gouvernement disait pas ça le
gouvernement disait si on fait des
économies et c'est ce qu'on fait les
Français on passera l'hiver sans
difficulté on n'a pas dit on n'a pas été
là j'entends certains qui disent on sait
pas si on va passer l'été en termes
d'eau là maintenant vous dites si jamais
c'est mieux on va pas se
nourrirez pas là-dessus on a assez de
catastrophiste catastrophisme de
collapsologue pour que je ne vienne pas
en rajouter il y a des difficultés dans
ce pays qui l'a dit avant-hier il a pas
dit qu'on allait manquer d'alimentation
non on peut aller vers une catastrophe
je pense que il faut qu'on dans une
démocratie les gens peuvent exprimer
leur colère peuvent exprimer leur
désaccord c'est tout à fait normal mais
n'essayons pas de rajouter du chaos au
chaos qui est au cas où ambiant du monde
je trouve qu'on en a déjà assez comme ça
mais parce qu'il pourrait quand même y
avoir si s'il y avait un ralentissement
avec enfin une grève
non mais jusqu'à nouvel ordre
jusqu'à la nouvelle heure depuis les
années 40 on a quand même toujours
nourri les Français on a eu la covid et
tout était en rade et on a nourri les
Français les agriculteurs ils ont été on
est sur le temps de la coopération il y
a des gens qui travaillent pour nourrir
les français
puisque nous sommes au salon de
l'agriculture ici on sent tout de même
de l'inquiétude alors hier vous avez
répondu par un plan fruit et légumes de
200 millions d'euros quels sont les
plans et les échéances aujourd'hui pour
soutenir l'ensemble de la filière
agricole français c'est c'est la
première illustration de la volonté
qu'on a de reprendre appartement par
appartement si vous permettez cette
expression une forme de souveraineté
alors ne soyons pas non plus blanc ou
noir dans cette affaire on est largement
souverain en céréales on est largement
souverain en l'air on est largement
souverain en fruits en vain enfin bref
on a plein en port enfin bref mais on a
un certain nombre de filières qui
effectivement souffert pour des raisons
diverses on pourrait revenir si vous le
voulez
d'une baisse de compétitivité qui fait
qu'on soit produit une baisse
et ça faut qu'on donne des messages de
moyens et long terme aux agriculteurs
oui parce que 70% des frites nous
mangeons sont d'origine étrangère en
France 60
comme un poulet sur deux par exemple
aussi qui vient donc de l'étranger
comment peut-on faire pour garder notre
souveraineté alimentaire en cette
période d'inflation où il y a une hausse
des coups de production bien sûr pour
l'ensemble de la filière agricole en
France
est-ce que c'est très emblématique aussi
de ce qu'il faut faire et de ce qu'il
faut améliorer on a une filière avicole
qui est bien organisée qui souffre
beaucoup mais on a couvert le besoin et
les difficultés je crois en partie de la
grippe aviaire
simplement on a une gamme qui fonctionne
bien les labels les animaux qui sont en
plein air et puis les produits de
l'entrée de gamme comme on dit là on a
un problème de compétitivité c'est à
dire que en faux en gros les 50% qui
nous manquent c'est plutôt sur l'entrée
de gamme ce qu'on mange y compris dans
du snacking comme on dit et sous
d'autres formes on a besoin d'avoir des
produits de haut de gamme des produits
de milieu de gamme et des produits
d'entrée de gamme on peut pas avoir
simplement une filière c'est quoi alors
parce que ça veut dire que c'est moins
bien élevé
mais c'est ce qu'on mange ouais c'est ce
qu'on mange et qui vient de l'étranger
donc il faut avoir tout dans un produit
évidemment les les cônes sont pas les
mêmes mais dans tous les cas et
d'ailleurs c'est ce sera des produits de
moins bonne qualité c'est pas des
produits de moins bonne qualité mais
c'est pas la même nature de produits
c'est pas les mêmes exigences que ça
porte mais c'est ce qu'on mange aussi et
donc de même que on mange pas tous les
jours une côte de bœuf mais on mange
plus régulièrement du steak haché et
c'est pas le même produit et c'est pas
le même coup et c'est pas le même
équilibre de matière Ière donc il faut
qu'on ait quelque chose qui soit de
l'ordre de l'équilibre économique sinon
on sera toujours défaillant sur une et
comment vous pouvez soutenir alors cette
filière d'entrée de gamme parce que on
l'a bien compris l'enjeu est là c'est un
sujet de compétitivité c'est un sujet de
ne pas surnormé par rapport à d'autres
pays alors voilà
une agricultrice tout à l'heure elle dit
on en peut plus en fait de l'ensemble et
alors après il faut
c'est c'est commode à dire moi derrière
le micro de dire foutant leur la paix ou
laisser les Français tranquille arrêtez
d'emmerder les Français avaient dit
président Pompidou je crois après il
faut essayer de le faire en raison parce
que nous sommes collectivement avec des
injonctions contradictoires c'est-à-dire
que nous sommes les premiers dès qu'il y
a un problème à demander une loi
collectivement
on a un sujet il faut une loi comme si
la loi les régler les problèmes on est
un pays qui légifère trop on est un pays
qui pense que
comme on n'est pas capable de compromis
comme on n'est pas l'intelligence
collective on a forcément besoin
d'interdire ou d'autoriser vous voyez ce
que je veux dire on a besoin
collectivement de se poser cette
question là et deux de veiller à chaque
fois parce qu'on est dans un marché
unique dans un marché européen
l'essentiel de nos concurrents sont pas
à l'autre bout du monde l'essentiel de
nos concurrents ils sont à nos
frontières c'est nos partenaires aussi
et donc on a besoin de regarder à chaque
fois qu'on produit de la norme
de faire en sorte que la norme soit
équivalente chez le voisin parce que de
toute façon mais ça est-ce que vous
pouvez l'imposer chez les voisins pour
qu'il respecte
vous le prenez à l'envers ah non vous le
prenez à l'envers alors prenons-le à
l'endroit avec vous essayez de ne pas
être arrogant et d'imposer la norme que
les voisins ne veulent pas alors comment
fait-on et ben on s'est vite de faire
nous-mêmes des normes bah oui mais alors
qui est en cause
mais allez-y je sais qu'on a besoin de
coupable et qu'en France
on va la jouer un peu différemment je
vais essayer en tout cas est-ce que
c'est pas mon genre et vous me
connaissez mais
quand vous décidez d'une norme EN FRANCE
et qu'après vous allez voir les autres
en disant sans avoir discuté avec eux
bah maintenant c'est la langue qui vous
imposer il est pas illégitime que les 26
autres lui disent mais t'es gentil tu es
passé devant mais à quel moment on en a
parlé il y a une forme arrogance à faire
ça et il y a une forme d'inconscient
aussi à faire ça parce que nous sommes
dans un marché unique c'est ce qui a
fait la richesse de l'Europe et les
richesses de la France y compris la
richesse agricole donc on a besoin en
France mais c'est parfois de la
réglementation c'est parfois de la loi
c'est parfois des choses qu'on voit pas
oui des pratiques donc c'est il y a pas
à mettre qui que ce soit là index c'est
un effort collectif que nous devons
faire pas que sur l'agriculture
objectivement j'ai je reste c'est
l'humunicipal et élu communautaire le
nombre de sujets sur lesquels on a le
sentiment qu'on en fait toujours
beaucoup plus que les autres ça nous
rend pas plus heureux d'ailleurs et ça
nous rend pas plein dans une société
beaucoup plus sûre je vais vous donner
un exemple
réutilisation des eaux du G ouais nous
sommes le pays qui réutilise le moins
les eaux usées pourquoi parce que en
France une espèce de
d'ambiance collective de oh là là c'est
des autres stations d'épuration c'est
des eaux qu'on appelle ça les eaux
grises que je n'aime pas trop c'est les
eaux qu'on jette au milieu qui sont
analysés en France il y a une culture
qui s'est développée dans les services
de la santé dans les services du
ministre dans les collectivement comme
citoyens sont réutilise surtout pas ces
eaux on est en train de produire un
décret en Conseil d'État avec mes
collègues de la santé de l'environnement
pour sortir de ça on utilise 1,8 % des
eaux usées les Italiens 15 les Allemands
disent les Espagnols 18 quand même ils
ont pas l'air en mauvaise santé quand
même mais ça c'est nous qui avons
surnommé et du coup c'est des
entreprises
il y a des expériences qui sont menées
et en plus on a la technologie on a les
meilleurs quand même les meilleurs
entreprises en termes de réutilisation
de l'eau c'est des gens qui exportent
leur savoir-faire à l'extérieur de nos
frontières et on n'est pas fichu de le
faire chez nous alors à propos de l'eau
c'est une grande préoccupation avec la
sécheresse en fait actuellement que que
faut-il faire là est-ce qu'il faut que
les agriculteurs donc
faut qu'il pleuve alors mais ça
évidemment ça ne nous appartient pas
puis il y a un problème de réchauffement
climatique probablement derrière tout ça
mais est-ce qu'il faut revoir aussi les
cultures alors le maïs deux choses deux
choses il y a le court terme c'est pour
ça que je disais il faut qu'il pleuve
parce que
parce que dans l'épisode qu'on traverse
qui est un peu atypique on n'a pas eu de
pluie peu en janvier pas du tout en
février on verra la semaine prochaine
qui s'annonce plus plus vieux fort
heureusement donc il faut naviguer entre
le court terme et le moyen terme parce
qu'on essaie de regarder c'est comment
on prépare une éventuelle sécheresse
enfin il tombe 600 mm en moyenne dans
mon territoire à la fin il va tomber 600
mm je me souviens 2016 où il était il
était pas tombé une goutte d'eau en
février en mars on irait en mars et en
avril on avait 80 cm d'eau dans mon
village en Beauce donc soyons prudents
n'étant ni Madame Irma ni météorologue
ça c'est le Courten court mais il faut
quand même se préparer au cas où puis
sur le temps long on a besoin
d'essayer d'utiliser l'eau sous toutes
les formes ce que je disais sur la
réutilisation on a besoin d'avoir des
systèmes qui soient économment non c'est
que par exemple vous utilisez du goutte
à goutte en arboriculture par exemple
vous économisez 40 ou 60% d'eau donc ça
c'est important toute goût d'eau doit
être utile je rappelle d'ailleurs que
l'on qui est mobilisé par les
agriculteurs c'est pas pour eux c'est
pour nous c'est pas de l'eau pour les
agriculteurs c'est de l'eau pour nous
donc faut diviser par 65 millions
d'habitants sinon on fait un une erreur
facture des gens disent les agriculteurs
accaparent l'eau c'est pas pour remplir
des piscines c'est pour nous nourrir
troisième élément donc on a besoin avec
eux d'avoir des systèmes plus économes
on a besoin d'avoir dans certains
territoires il y a des il y aura des
évolutions d'assolement est-ce qu'ici il
y a moins de maïs c'est ce qui s'y a
plus de maïs c'est ce qu'ici il y a plus
on a un système par exemple d'élevage
qui est très basé sur les prairies le
système basé sur les prairies va être un
peu chahuté par le dérèglement
climatique dur il y aura besoin
peut-être dans ces élevages
paradoxalement d'un peu de maïs donc un
peu d'accès progressive
est-ce que vous n'avez pas fait
d'ailleurs ils sont pas caricaturer le
modèle et de le faire évoluer parce que
le réchauffement climatique ça donne
s'imposer à nous oui Marcelo il nous
reste trois minutes je voudrais qu'on en
vienne aussi à cette question
effectivement d'inflation alors on a
parlé beaucoup d'un panier
anti-inflation les agriculteurs
n'étaient pas forcément favorables on a
entendu Christiane Lambert par exemple
quelle mesure quelle planette
pourrait-il y avoir pour justement
l'ensemble des dents et alimentaires
alors c'est plutôt là c'est plutôt
inflation donc c'est
on a besoin quand même c'est tout
l'objet des Gallim 1 et Gallim 2 on a
besoin quand même de faire en sorte
qu'on rémunère les producteurs c'est pas
la peine de parler de souveraineté si on
rémunir pas les producteurs c'est autant
arrêter tout de suite le le débat sur la
souveraineté si on n'est pas capable de
dire au producteurs qu'on va les payer
au juste prix parce que c'est un juste
coup deuxième élément on est dans une
phase inflationniste qui est liée à la
guerre en Ukraine je vais pas vous
redire ce qui a été dit souvent sur vos
antennes on a besoin de regarder alors
ces paniers anti-inflation ou autre
dispositifs Bruno Le Maire a redit hier
ou avant-hier si j'ai bonne mémoire que
il continue à y travailler c'est d'avoir
sur un certain nombre de produits la
garantie qui sont stables et qu'ils sont
mais ça a une condition c'est ce qui a
rappelé Bruno Le Maire c'est que la
stabilité des prix ne se fait pas au
prix des producteurs et au prix des
transformateurs et donc il reste un
dernier élément et un dernier maillon de
la chaîne c'est les distributeurs les
distributeurs là il faut qu'il fasse des
efforts mais
je suis suffisamment comment dirais-je
instruis de ce qui se passe généralement
pour que les parfois à certains
distributeurs disent je fais des efforts
et qu'à la fin ça se termine chez le
consommateur chez le producteur donc
c'est ça qu'on est en train de calibrer
ce que c'est un panier est-ce que c'est
une autre formule et sous quinzaine on
aura un dispositif qui sera calé je peux
pas vous en dire plus qu'on est en train
d'essayer de calibrer dans une quinzaine
de jours il y aura des éléments qui
visent à passer ce pic inflationniste et
à l'alimentation on dit que le pic sera
plutôt pour le mois d'avril parce qu'on
a dit mars au début et là il aurait
peut-être vers le mois d'avril le vrai
ou pas ben on avait dit mars on dit moi
d'avril on dit mois d'avril c'est enfin
voilà on va pas là non plus j'en ai pas
Madame Irma on essaie de se mettre en
disposition pour éviter les pics je
rappelle qu'en février on avait dit
c'est affreux on va avoir 20%
d'inflation et que la France a fait 6%
d'inflation oui parce qu'on y travaille
parce qu'on s'en occupe sérieusement
avec cette inflation est-ce que la
filière bio est menacée
avec cette inflation la filière bio à
terme si ça durait dans la structure de
la demande de la filière bio pourrait en
grand risque c'est le c'est le sens des
premières annonces qui a pu faire la
première ministre Elisabeth borne et de
la volonté qu'on a nous
de faire en sorte de faire passer le cap
on a un choc de demande là on a une
filière beau qui ne trouve plus sa
clientèle donc on a besoin de travailler
pour éviter que des agriculteurs se
déconvertissent on a besoin de
travailler pour passer le cap en terme à
part la communication pour que des gens
reviennent vers le bureau et on a besoin
sur le long terme de structurer une
c'est un segment de marché parce que le
bio on voit bien a été un peu chahuté
par la proximité le localisme qui est
aussi une autre version de la volonté
des gens de se réapproprier leur
alimentation donc faut qu'on travaille
immédiatement pour éviter un choc qui
fasse fermer des boutiques ou des
convertir des producteurs là il y a un
risque dans les dans les semaines qui
viennent il y a un risque dans les
semaines qui viennent donc on est en
train de travailler de regarder comment
on peut faire passer ce cap et puis une
responsabilité de la grande distribution
aussi les rayons bio ils vont nous dire
oui mais ça correspond plus la demande
oui au moment où ça allait bien et
c'était la croissance des chiffres ils
ont ils ont rempli les rayons il faut
toujours se méfier des croissances à
deux chiffres et puis donc maintenant
ils ont une responsabilité c'est qu'il y
a une filière bio et qui a une filaire
d'eau pour la soutenir font que ça soit
proposé aux clients et puis peut-être
une dernière question consacrer plus
générale et de philosophie par rapport à
l'agriculture Marc féno il y avait une
agricultrice de ce matin qui nous disait
ras-le-bol on est stigmatisé les
agriculteurs on nous tape dessus
maltraitance animale
maltraitance aussi de l'environnement
est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas faire
davantage de pédagogie de campagne de
communication c'est ce qu'elle réclamait
tout à l'heure c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire à votre antenne là oui oui bien
sûr
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des actions en
fait
on va pas faire il faut faire de la
pédagogie mais la pédagogie c'est pas
une action choc c'est tous les jours
d'expliquer parce que c'est le site de
l'eau ce que c'est que l'alimentation ce
que c'est que d'être éleveur l'utilité
de l'élevage et ne pas se soumettre aux
vidéos des uns et des autres qui sont
des vidéos qui sont souvent assez
virales mais qui sont absolument
destructrices des informations là à ce
niveau là oui enfin quand vous prenez
vous encapsulez une vidéo et que vous
résumez l'élevage à une situation dans
un cas particulier de chaque personne
dans sa je te contexte évidemment c'est
une des professions
elles sont peu nombreuses mais c'est une
profession qui travaille à ciel ouvert
aux yeux de tous quels sont témoins
juste titre d'être très stigmatisé à
très grande injustice par des gens qui
ne connaissent rien souvent en tout cas
ceux qui parlent parler d'une partie des
écolos là c'est ça je parle de je veux
même pas qualifier politiquement où ils
sont enfin c'est des gens qui
comprennent pas ce que c'est qu'un cycle
qui comprennent pas et qui sont dans la
logique du Yakin faucon les mêmes qui
ont nous ont expliqué qu'il fallait
sortir du nucléaire et qui maintenant
sont les bras ballants en disant c'est
incroyable on sait pas faire de les
mêmes qui vous disent quand on fait pas
du nucléaire que l'éolien ça va pas
parce que ceci que le solaire ça va pas
parce que cela que la méthanisation ça
va pas moi je vais vous dire faut pas
qu'on s'occupe trop de ces gens là parce
que ces gens-là ils nous amènent à la
catastrophe on l'a fait il la voir sur
le nucléaire il n'est pas question pour
moi que sur la souveraineté alimentaire
parce qu'on écouterait des gens qui au
bout je dis pas que c'est leur projet
mais qui au bout amène l'agriculture à
sa perte et les agriculteurs à leur
perte je laisserai pas faire et c'est
bien la volonté du gouvernement de ne
pas laisser faire merci Marc fenault
l'agriculture et de la souverain